farmers continue their protest on a
major highway connecting india's most
populous state uttar pradesh to the
capital region of delhi
they've stopped all traffic on this and
two other
key roads for nearly seven weeks and say
they won't stop
despite the supreme court suspending the
implementation of three farm laws
they've been protesting against
they're also not hopeful about the
committee the top court has formed
to look into the laws
the members of the committee are
pro-government people who have supported
the three farm laws and other government
recommendations
their ideology is anti-farmer and they
are in favor of market reforms
that are part of the farm bills
the protests began after the government
passed three agriculture laws in
september
which encouraged india's farmers to sell
directly to large corporations
they intensified in november when
farmers from the states of punjab
haryana and uttar pradesh
marched hundreds of kilometers to delhi
and occupied highways
yogendra singh has been at the gazebo
protest site for six weeks
our demands have to be fulfilled by the
government and then if all the farmers
leave i will too
but if other farmers stay i will stay we
told our family members back home not to
wait for us
since no one knows when we will return
we left our family behind for this
farmers say they're afraid that once the
laws are implemented
they'll lose minimum prices for their
produce which have been guaranteed by
the government for decades
dozens of farmers have died camping out
in the cold over the past six weeks
including one here in gazipur yesterday
the supreme court took note of the
deaths the number of elderly people
women and children at the demonstrations
and said it's extremely disappointed
with the government's handling of the
protests
the government maintains that the laws
are in the interest of farmers by giving
them
access to new and bigger markets but
with farmers suspicious not just of the
government
but also the makeup of the supreme
court's committee
india's biggest protest since prime
minister narendra modi was first elected
six years ago is set to continue
elizabeth puranam al-jazeera
gazipur